and finally new rule if something about
the human race is changing at a
previously unprecedented rate
we have to at least discuss it
broken down over time the lgbt
population of america seems to be
roughly doubling every generation
according to a recent gallup poll
less than one percent of americans born
before 1946 that's joe biden's
generation identify that way 2.6 percent
of boomers do 4.2 of gen x 10.5 of
millennials and 20.8 percent of gen z
which means if we follow this trajectory
we will all be gay in 2054.
[Applause]
and then who's going to buy this chair
i'm just saying that when things change
this much this fast people are allowed
to ask what's up with that
all the babies are in the wrong bodies
was there a mix-up at the plant like
with cap'n crunches oops all berries
[Applause]
it wasn't that long ago when adults
asked a kid what do you want to be when
you grow up they meant what profession
[Applause]
in the wake of america about to lose
abortion rights the aclu recently
tweeted a list of those who would be
disproportionately harmed by this you
would think women might top that list
no wasn't even on the list second on the
list was lgbt really
abortion rights affects gay and trans
people more than
you know
breeders
i'm happy for lgbt folks that we now
live in an age where they can live their
authentic lives openly and we should
always be mindful of respecting and
protecting
but someone needs to say it not
everything's about you
[Applause]
and it's okay to ask questions about
something that's very new and involves
children the answer can't always be that
anyone from a marginalized community is
automatically right trump card might
drop end of discussion
because we're literally experimenting on
children
maybe that's why sweden and finland have
stopped giving puberty blockers to kids
because we just don't know much about
the long-term effects although common
sense should tell you that when you
reverse the course of raging hormones
there's going to be problems
we do know it hinders the development of
bone density which is kind of important
if you like having a skeleton
fertility and the ability to have an
orgasm seem also to be affected this
isn't just a lifestyle decision it's
medical
weighing trade-offs is not bigotry
yet when a book questioning the sudden
uptick in transitioning children was
released a trans lawyer with the aclu
named chase strangio
tweeted stopping the circulation of this
book and these ideas is 100 a hill i
will die on
how very civil liberties of him
chase by the way has just been named one
of the grand marshals of this year's new
york city pride march
along with three other trans people and
a lesbian huh what's missing here
oh right a gay man
that's where we are now gay men aren't
hip enough for the gay pride parade
compared to trans gay is practically cis
and cis is practically mormon
[Applause]
and this is a phenomenon we need to take
into account when we look at this issue
yes part of the rise in lgbt numbers is
from people feeling free enough to tell
it to a pollster and that's all to the
good but some of it is
it's trendy
penis equals man okay boomer
remember the prime directive of every
team is anything to shock and challenge
the squares who brought you up
it's why nobody gets a nose ring at
[Applause]
56. and if you haven't noticed that with
kids doing something for the likes is
more important than their own genitals
you haven't been paying attention
dr erica anderson is a prominent 71 year
old clinical psychologist who is herself
transgender and who now says i think
it's gone too far
the la times summarizes she's come to
believe that some children identifying
as trans are falling under the influence
of their peers and social media
if you attend a small dinner party of
typically very liberal upper income
angelinos
it is not uncommon to hear parents who
each have a trans kid having a
conversation about that what are the
odds of that happening in youngstown
ohio
if this spike in trans children is all
natural
why is it regional
either ohio is shaming them or
california is creating them
[Applause]
it's like that day we suddenly all
needed bottled water all the time
if we can't admit that in certain
enclaves there is some level of
trendiness to the idea of being anything
other than straight then this is not a
serious science-based discussion
it's a blow being struck in the culture
wars using children as cannon fodder
i don't understand parents who won't let
their nine-year-old walk to the corner
without a helmet an epipen and a gps
tracker
and god forbid their lips touch dairy
but
[Applause]
but hormone blockers and genital surgery
fine
talk about a nut allergy
[Applause]
i uh i guess penises are gross now but
one might come in handy later on
and if you're a man who wants to
experience life without a pair of balls
you do not have to get surgery you can
get married
[Applause]
and never forget children are
impressionable and very very stupid
kids don't know why mom drinks every day
or
why dad has two cell phones
maybe the boy who thinks he's a girl is
just gay
or whatever frazier was
[Applause]
maybe the girl who hates girly stuff
just needs to learn that being female
doesn't mean you have to act like a
kardashian
[Applause]
maybe childhood makes you sad sometimes
and there are other solutions besides
hand me the dick saw
and look
i'm sure the vast majority of parents do
not take this lightly
and that is very hard to know when
something is real or just a phase
and i understand being trans is
different it's innate but kids do also
have phases they're kids it's all phases
the dinosaur phase the hello kitty phase
one day they want to be an astronaut the
next day you can't get them to leave
their room
gender fluid kids are fluid about
everything if kids knew what they wanted
to be at age eight the world would be
filled with cowboys and princesses
[Applause]
i wanted to be a pirate
right
thank god nobody took me seriously and
scheduled me for eye removal and peg leg
surgery
you